drama humanitario censarse band ucrania
en la semana 11 de hostilidades y
ataques indiscriminados del ejército
ruso naciones unidas dice que las
víctimas civiles superan por miles a las
más de 7000 reportadas por el propio
organismo entre heridos y fallecidos en
total hasta la fecha hemos corroborado 7
mil 61 víctimas civiles con tres mil 381
muertos y tres mil 680 heridos en todo
el país desde el inicio del ataque
armado de la federación rusa las cifras
reales son mayores y estamos trabajando
para corroborar cada uno de los
incidentes
las cifras representan un agujero negro
especialmente en ciudades como mariupol
dado que los incesantes bombardeos del
kremlin impiden la entrada de los
organismos internacionales para
esclarecer las violaciones de derechos
humanos cometidas durante más de dos
meses de asedio son las autoridades
locales al menos 100 civiles continúan
atrapados en el último reducto de
resistencia ucraniana la acería de aces
tal y miles más en las inmediaciones de
la arrasada urbe
debemos de entender que en mariupol hay
más de 100 mil civiles que están
esperando que se les dé la oportunidad
de salir y que tengan no sólo el deseo
sino también la oportunidad de salvar
sus por lo tanto instó a todos a unirse
y a no rendirse en esta situación tan
difícil
hospitales escuelas o teatros que son
refugio han sido atacados la
organización mundial de la salud
denunció la muerte de al menos tres mil
personas por falta de acceso a sus
tratamientos médicos o moscú hándicaps
con casi 200 ataques sanitarios
verificados y documentados por la ome s
sobre el terreno q crearía es testigo
del mayor y más rápido asalto al sistema
sanitario a su personal y a sus
pacientes and space y la emergencia
humanitaria se traduce también en el
número de desplazados internos más de 8
millones de ucranianos huyeron de sus
hogares para proteger sus vidas el 63%
son mujeres y 6 millones han salido del
país más de 8 millones de personas han
sido desplazadas internamente en ucrania
necesitan desesperadamente dinero en
efectivo medicinas y refugio por su
parte moscú continúa negando ataques a
la población civil y califica su
invasión como una operación militar
especial